germany takes over the chair of the g7
this year putting it in the midst of
some major challenges facing this club
of rich democracies
it's an early test on the world stage
for the new chancellor olaf schultz
after he took over from angela merkel
the pandemic will likely dominate the
agenda with the g7 under pressure to do
more to end the huge inequality and
access to vaccines around the world and
on climate change schultz is expected to
push his idea of a climate club that's a
plan to help like-minded countries
coordinate their emission targets
and one key question will schultz pursue
u.s president joe biden's efforts to get
democracies to rally together
against
china
and we are now joined by dw's chief
international editor richard walker uh
richard this is all of trolls debut as a
host
of a big international group following
in angela merkel's footsteps there
what can we expect from him
yeah they are pretty big footsteps are
following of course aren't they um
gerhard angela merkel in office for 16
years she chaired two g7 summits during
her time so that summit coming up in
june this year will be olaf schultz's
real debut on this kind of premier level
of the international stage as host
but as finance minister in his previous
role over the past four years he
certainly has had exposure to this kind
of level of diplomacy
and his people point to uh something of
a success last year where he was one of
the driving forces behind
we reported on this the idea of a global
minimum tax for corporations to try to
uh prevent especially big tech giants
from kind of free riding on taxes by uh
setting up their taxes in low tax
economies so that was very much an olaf
schultz initiative and i think we can
expect to see more initiatives from him
uh like that on the world stage but what
he is not is the kind of like chest
thumping guy who's going to stand up on
the stage and say this is the way we're
going to do things he's softly spoken he
has that in common with angela merkel
well charles wants to use its presidency
of the the g7 to develop it into a
climate club what what's his
plan yeah well this is the the prime
example we can expect to hear this
expression uh a climate club uh quite a
bit this year now it's an idea that's
been going around in academic circles
for a few years and it's trying to
tackle this problem that we've had with
climate change treaties over the years
that there aren't enough incentives for
countries to really follow through on
the promises
that they make and at the heart of this
is cost if you want to cut climate
change if you want to fight climate
change you need to raise the price of
polluting carbon and countries worry
that if they do that in their country
then companies might just up sticks to
other countries especially big
industries and
move their operations there where they
don't pay such a high price for carbon
so the idea with a carbon climate club
is that you get a group of like-minded
countries that want to press ahead
that set roughly equivalent standards on
the pricing of carbon on the pricing of
pollution and other things and they
agree to trade under favorable terms
with each other and crucially countries
that are outside it don't get those
favorable terms so that's an incentive
for those countries to join so you can
expect olaf schultz to be bringing this
up at the g7 this year and trying to use
it as a springboard for this idea
so uh how likely is this to be
successful then how big is germany's and
olaf schultz influence in this club of
rich countries
well i think
he certainly has potential as a
mobilizer to get something like this
going but the big question about the
climate club basing it around the g7
would be well is it enough if you don't
have really big economies like china
involved and you already have industry
associations in germany saying exactly
that if china's not involved in
something like this then what can it
really achieve and that kind of opens up
to the bigger question about the
relevance of the g7 whether the g20 this
much broader grouping that includes
china also countries from the global
south is more the kind of forum that to
get ideas like this really
to take effect
uw's chief international editor richard
walker there thank you richard
you